Traductor: Catalina Aguirre
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
Viviendo con su familia en las alturas
en los bosques tropicales
del norte de Colombia,
encontrarás a Shakira,
una muy conversadora
tití cabeciblanco.
Dice, "¡Hola!"
Aunque tal vez
no te des cuenta,
este mono de medio
kilo se comunica
en un lenguaje altamente sofisticado
de 38 distintos llamados
basados en variaciones
de gorjeos y silbidos.
La respuesta que ella da es
conocida como "gorjeo B",
un llamado usualmente
dirigido a humanos.
Para apreciar las complejidades
del lenguaje de Shakira,
aprendamos algunos gorjeos y silbidos,
y luego examinemos
como sus combinaciones
forman secuencias estructuradas
gramaticalmente.
El gorjeo que usa Shakira
para saludarnos
viene de una clase de
llamados conocida como
sílabas moduladas
de una sola frecuencia.
Está hecha de llamados de
corta duración o gorjeos
y llamados largos,
como gritos y chillidos.
Los investigadores han
determinado que hay 8
diferentes tipos de
gorjeos categorizados
por su tronco elevado o no, duración,
frecuencia máxima y cambio de frecuencia.
Adicionalmente, cada gorjeo
tiene su significado único.
Por ejemplo, Shakira
usa el "gorjeo C"
cuando se acerca a la comida,
mientras que su "gorjeo D" lo usa solo
cuando tiene
la comida en sus manos.
Silbidos solos muestran una
intención única con cada llamado
y así como hay 8 diferentes gorjeos,
hay 5 diferentes silbidos.
Basados en la frecuencia
de modulación,
los silbidos individuales
se subdividen en 4 categorías:
chillidos, silbidos modulados al inicio,
silbidos modulados al final,
y silbidos planos.
La cualidad del lenguaje
de intención única
esta maravillosamente
ejemplificada por la categoría
de silbidos modulados al inicio.
Estos silbidos cambian de
acuerdo a la proximidad
de Shakira a otro
miembro de su familia.
Si Shakira está a más
de 60 cm de su familia,
dará un largo silbido
modulado al inicio.
Pero si está a menos de
60 cm de su familia,
dará un pequeño silbido
modulado al inicio.
Ahora que hemos aprendido
unos pocos gorjeos y silbidos,
Shakira quiere
presumir llevándote
rápidamente a un día en
su vida con estos llamados.
Mientras se dirige a un árbol a tomar
su primera comida del día,
dice, (ruido de monos),
un llamado usado
en investigaciones tranquilas.
Sin embargo, de repente
ve la sombra de un halcón.
"Gorjeo E" de alarma.
Este llamado alerta a su familia
de la presencia de este depredador,
y Shakira salta a ponerse
a salvo debajo de una rama.
Nada en el horizonte,
Shakira se dirige hacia su padre.
Momento, momento.
¿Quién es ese?
Ah, su hermano menor, Carlos.
Los tití cabeciblanco suelen chillar
mientras juegan a luchar.
Uh-oh. Él está jugando
un poco rudo y Shakira grita,
alertando a sus padres
para que la ayuden.
Su padre se acerca a la bola
de pelos rodando
y su hermano para.
Shakira se sacude
y se rasca para poner
el pelo de su cabeza
en su lugar.
Entonces Shakira nota
un grupo desconocido de titís
y oye su usual llamado largo.
Se vuelve a su familia.
(Ruido de monos)
¿Notaste eso? Primero fue
un gorjeo, luego un silbido.
Esto es lo que conocemos
como vocalización combinada,
una frase que contiene
ambos gorjeos y silbidos.
Estos son dos llamados unidos
para transmitir un mensaje.
La combinación de
estos dos elementos
alerta a su familia de
la presencia de otro grupo,
el "gorjeo F" y la distancia
a la cual se encuentran,
el llamado tipo
silbido largo normal.
En otras palabras,
Shakira acaba de decir una frase.
Su simple demostración es solo
la punta del iceberg.
Ella tiene gorjeos, conversaciones,
múltiples silbidos de llamado,
más combinaciones de
vocalizaciones, incluso trinos.
Pero lo más triste es que
tal vez no lleguemos a oír
todo lo que ella
tiene que decir.
Mezclado en lo alto con
las sonatas de trinos
está el constante ruido de
un machete cortando árboles.
El hábitat de Shakira en Colombia
está siendo cortado,
pieza por pieza,
y si no trabajamos para proteger
al tití cabeciblanco que
se encuentra en peligro crítico,
se extinguirá en nuestra vida.
Si el grito de un tití a otro
ha probado ser más
que un ocioso charlar,
imagina todo lo que
nos queda por descubrir.
Imagina todo lo que
Shakira nos puede decir.